these are cooling and heating units for
industrial buildings soon they'll be
shipped to the US Pakistan Bangladesh
and Mexico the manufacturer broad group
a company headquartered in Hunan China
specializes in energy efficient air
conditioning in the next few years the
firm with more than 3,000 employees
hopes to further expand aided by China's
belt and road investment scheme belt and
road opens a new space for growth in the
world economy it creates a new platform
for international trade and investment
and provides new ways for global
economic governance and contributes to
the well-being of people in many
countries sometimes called the New Silk
Road the belt and Road initiative is a
massive infrastructure investment scheme
new railways are intended to provide
better connectivity across the Eurasian
continent investment in ports will open
new maritime trading routes according to
official figures the total value of
projects already signed exceeds 500
billion u.s. dollars
the projects are largely carried out by
Chinese state-owned firms they've gained
experience with big construction
projects during China's own
infrastructure push of the past 40 years
but there is criticism of the
international initiative many Western
countries including Germany are
reluctant to sign bilateral belt and
Road agreements concerns for
participating partner countries range
from the environmental cost to
sustainability of jet levels in some
places China friendly governments have
been voted out of office in view of
China's own mega construction boom
critics call many of the Chinese
investment projects over ambitious the
biggest lesson for the Chinese
government was that you cannot just go
ahead and build what you want you have
to consider what local governments and
people want and how the international
community reacts what you show with a
fan you if you ask whether backlashes in
some of those countries came as a
surprise to the Chinese government I
would say it was not just a surprise it
was a shock shock so far international
trade rules have been shaped by Western
countries Chinese companies like broad
hope that through its massive
investments China will gain a greater
say in these rules to make them better
serve Chinese businesses China's
ambitions are on the table it's now up
to the rest of the world to react
and femoral this let's cross over to our
DW correspondent in type aids Oh dong
hun so nice to see you as always so you
saw that report what are China's
ambitions with the belton Road
initiative well to eventually get more
influence and control in the world we
know this from another name of the
project that is the Silk Road it's the
ancient network of trade routes that
connected China and the Roman Empire and
many societies in between so the modern
version envisioned by Chinese President
Xi Jinping goes further to partner with
more countries in Asia Europe and Africa
and beyond
so that is Chinese government's biggest
ambition so you mentioned the original
Silk Road linking as far as the Roman
Empire what about this version of the
Silk Road
what role does Europe play in it well
it's part of China's plan we know some
belkin countries will eventually become
EU member state some as early as 2025 so
China is using its companies to fill in
the development gaps in this
cash-strapped countries to get more
influences so let's say with these
infrastructures built by China in the
world's belkin's China can ship its
goods from Greek through the West
belkin's into EU common market of over
half a billion costumers and that of
course leads to political ramifications
when it comes to integration of those
European nations into the EU how about
now this year as China's economy has
slowed has that slowed these ambitions
at all well not really country two that
China has left forward on infrastructure
related this project in other countries
and send its workers abroad not only
that China has a new project called
digital soccer old to promote its
biggest telecom company Huawei so all
these projects are considered to be a
economic boost for the Chinese economy
all right so Jeong Ha joining us there
in Taipei thank you very much